[Music]
I was leading a double life well that's
true unfortunately one was secret and
the other one was boring send Dan makes
transitioning from a Disney Channel icon
to a Hollywood star look effortless but
growing up in the Disney Channel family
wasn't always easy for the actor turned
activists keep watching to find out the
real reason zendaya chose to leave her
Disney Channel days behind her from fake
friendships and rumours to stereotypes
and the fear of being typecast watch
until the very end to find out what
advice the star has to offer to anyone
thinking of joining the industry you
ready technically zendaya didn't get her
start on the Disney Channel long before
she danced her way onto the set of shake
it up she attended the Oakland School
for the Arts where she starred in dozens
of stage productions she was practically
born into the limelight thanks to her
mother Claire Marie who worked as the
house manager of the Shakespeare Theatre
in California zendaya was enrolled in
the theaters a student conservatory
program where she was molded into the
perfect child star but long before she
snagged the role of rocky blue
zendaya joined the future shocked
Oakland dance group where she focused on
hip hop dancing from ages 8 to 11 from
there
zendaya worked as a model for Macy's
Mervyn's and Old Navy and soon after she
was featured as a commercial actor in a
toy ad for iCarly this helped her gain
recognition and she was soon cast in a
Sears commercial with Disney Channel's
very own Selena Gomez in 2009
zendaya even filmed a Kidz Bop music
video in which she covered the song hot
and cold that same year she would
audition for the role of Cece Jones and
receive a life-changing phone call you
didn't sign us up for dance boot camp
you signed us up for major dances
zendaya blue disney channel executives
away when she performed Michael
Jackson's leave me alone while
auditioning for the role of Cece Jones
and soon she got a call back saying that
she had been selected for the role of
rocky blue in
stat of Cece Jones zendaya was excited
to work with her co-star Bella Thorne
and the two eventually became good
friends but despite all the good things
Disney Channel had to offer
zendaya quickly found out that life as a
Disney star wasn't all it was cracked up
to be
shake it up was an instant hit but
according to bella thorne filming season
1 wasn't all that great during an
interview with j14 Bella revealed that
she and zendaya were constantly compared
to each other by Disney Channel
executives the girls felt like they were
stuck in an endless game of who's better
at this and who's better at that there
was so much pressure on the set of shake
it up the girls had trouble connecting
to one another luckily both Bella and
zendaya realized what was happening and
chose to have a tell-all talk which
helped them become close but despite the
lack of animosity between the co-stars
people could not stop comparing them to
each other online publications released
articles asking people to vote on which
teenage girl was more beautiful which is
seriously tainted their Disney Channel
experience but being compared to others
was just one of the many problems and
daya would encounter you do realize
you're not speaking English or Japanese
right by the time zendaya made waves as
rocky blue on shaken up she was already
well-versed on what it meant to be in
the public eye still there are plenty of
rules when it comes to joining the
Disney Channel family and they are not
always easy to live by on top of being
instructed on what to wear and say
during interviews zendaya had to shed
her individuality to stay in line with
the Disney brand everything from
Zendaya's personal style to social media
posts were decided for her during an
interview with clever TV in 2011 zendaya
revealed that her life consisted of
travelling the world to promote her show
while having to perfect choreographies
in just three days so like we learn it
in the morning for like two hours
however the star did admit that she
enjoyed having a busy schedule but
whether or not zendaya was instructed to
say that is up for debate keep watching
to find out why zendaya had to take a
step back from social media to protect
her mental health
okay thank you from that old bat if it
kills me by the time shake it up was
canceled in 2013 zendaya was already 17
years old which is typically the age
actors choose to part ways with the
Disney Channel
Sandhya already had tons of
opportunities lined up outside of Disney
so she told Disney executives that she
was thinking of leaving and they asked
her what it would take for her to stay
once the ball was in Zendaya's court she
got to thinking that if she stayed she
could help push Disney in the right
direction during an interview with
Seventeen magazine
zendaya said the only way she was going
to come back to the Disney Channel was
if she was in a position of power so the
star worked out a very special contract
with the house of mouse so what you're
saying is we could all die on this job
which secured her spot with Disney for
another three years but during this time
zendaya still managed to land roles in
movies like Spider Man homecoming the
greatest showman and small foot which
was unusual for a Disney Channel star
okay if we're gonna do this we got to do
it fast
ragi telling the plan oh but before
zendaya signed on to star in the TV
movie zapped and the hit TV show Casey
Undercover she wanted to make sure that
the show would be very different than
what Disney Channel was used to mainly
she wanted to be a part of a show that
represented families of color which she
felt Disney Channel was lacking she
wanted the network to have more
diversity she opened up about how
difficult it was for children of color
to look at the TV and not see anyone who
looked like them so she agreed to come
back to the Disney Channel as long as
she could have a hand in what Casey
undercover would be about determined to
get her on board Disney executives gave
zendaya a co-producer role allowing her
to make important decisions during an
interview with Disney in 2015 zendaya
said that Casey undercover was different
from other shows because it didn't focus
on singing dancing or the arts according
to zendaya the show was about family is
about kicking butt and see
in early February of 2018 zendaya took
to Twitter to tell fans that she was
officially leaving the Disney Channel
she posted a picture of herself in the
iconic Disney Channel logo and captioned
it the end of an era on to the next
thank you for continuing to grow with me
now at this point
zendaya felt that she had successfully
created a show that was both diverse and
empowering and now that it was over it
was time for her to move on during her
time in the Disney Channel family
zendaya realized that there was still a
long way to go when it came to equality
after years of feeling like she did not
have a voice she realized that she did
and she wanted to use it to help others
during an interview with Glamour
magazine zendaya said that people can't
quite understand what it's like to grow
up and not see yourself in mainstream
media she added that there is so much
work left to be done the star went on to
say that as her social media platforms
grew she realized that her voice was so
much more important than she had
originally thought zendaya strongly
believes that if every young person
understood the power of their voice
things would be a lot different
zendaya used the hardships that she
encountered on the Disney Channel as
fuel to become an activist who strives
for justice and equality the star was
excited to put her Disney Channel days
behind her however she was also happy
that she had seen and understood what
truly went on behind the scenes of the
network
getting your start on the Disney Channel
can be quite the gamble
while some child actors go on to become
the next big thing in Hollywood others
missed the mark and get typecast zendaya
knew this was a possibility which is why
she chose to start auditioning for roles
both bore she parted ways with Disney
and so she decided to audition for the
role of Michelle in the spider-man
franchise but zendaya was certain that
she wouldn't be cast as MJ who was
typically portrayed by a redheaded
Caucasian woman
zendaya was so used to having to fight
for diversity on the Disney Channel she
was positive that she wouldn't land the
part to boost her chances zendaya chose
to straighten her hair like she had done
countless times before on the set of
shake it up surprisingly Marvel was
already interested in diversifying the
cast of the film and chose to give the
role to the actor who impressed them the
most which turned out to be zendaya
zendaya told Marie Claire that she was
shocked when she got the news unlike
what the Disney Channel zendaya didn't
have to push Marvel executives to break
the rules because they were already
breaking them what are you hiding Peter
after leaving Disney zendaya was finally
allowed to choose her own clothes and
she quickly became a staple in the
fashion industry better yet she was
finally free to audition for more mature
roles and like most Disney Channel stars
zendaya chose to pursue a darker role to
show her fans that she was far more from
one-dimensional she made the decision to
take on more mature projects and soon
zendaya was cast as Roo Bennett in HBO's
euphoria but instead of being happy for
her zendaya is former Disney Channel
fans attacked her online and judged her
for appearing in a more mature program I
miss you I can do that a lot better than
you can instead of adding fuel to the
fire zendaya remained professional and
reminded fans that it's important not to
judge any other person's career or
trajectories and they also sat down with
Vogue Australia to remind people that
growing up in front of the world isn't
always easy she urged fans to remember
that everyone
has their own path I think she just goes
about it away that's probably just not
healthy growing up under the public eye
wasn't always easy for zendaya who often
received a backlash for the most
surprising reasons like taking on a new
role during an interview with Teen Vogue
zendaya stressed the importance of not
letting social media consume you the
star even tweeted that as much as she
loves the industry she values her
happiness and sanity a lot more zendaya
might be a bona fide celebrity but she
always keeps things real and does her
best to keep her private life well
private which is a tip she quickly
picked up after joining the Disney
Channel family and I tried to do that
with everything that I do I try to be as
positive and is loving it and that's a
wrap on the dark side of Zendaya's
disney channel experience before you go
tell us which one of Zendaya's roles has
been your favorite so far in the
comments below thanks for tuning in for
more fun content be sure to LIKE this
video and subscribe to the things we'll
see you next time
[Music]